so I'm Teddy I'm a PhD candidate at the
University of Calgary just finishing up
in August so what work we did here at
the Microsoft Research is something
called Project
álava so what it's about at a high level
and James look kind of explain a bit
more later is they're making it really
easy for people to program
microcontrollers or things that are kind
of small computers they're typically
hard for non-technical to code well
obviously you think about people in sort
of the broader world there's a lot of
people that are really creative but also
maybe not so technical and so what we
looked at was making it easy for them to
be creative with technology one of the
first examples we looked at was fashion
so what we designed was these things
called the brained and something called
a bead so the brain is something you
would code in a browser using my code
which will kind of explain it but
shortly and a bead so bead is something
like a sensor and so we did things like
making it very color-coded so you kind
of know what that sensor looks like and
what kind of functionality it has so
functionality can be things like
accelerometer proximity or color as I
said these are all programmed in a
browser we assorted things like smart
tattoos
so after rows away who's a fashion
technologist in a creative engineer here
at Microsoft Research she does things
with smart tattoos so we made it easy
for people to be able to cut these
tattoos and forget them into the browser
in this demo here you kind of see we
have what I mentioned was the brain
that's this thing up here and a bunch of
different sensors hooked up to it using
audio track cables which is used as the
protocol called jack-jack which teams
will come explain in a moment and if you
kind of look over here we have a tattoo
sensor and so if I touch her hand it
should light up so we made it really
easy for people that are creative
specifically fashion designers to do
things like this we ran a full Fashion
Show in New York with 22 designers
comparing traditional fashion design
with technique you sit into it and they
all created different types of garments
and that is what we did with project
lava and I will now hand it off to James
hi I'm James Devon I'm from Lancaster
University I'm a PhD candidate there so
Teddy said Teddy mentioned one of the
big challenges was the program
environment and I'm going to highlight
the program environment on this computer
here so this is mate code make it bigger
it's a it's a block based programming
environment primarily it's drag-and-drop
programming so I can drag-and-drop
click my blocks together very much like
scratch and then if I get super
proficient with the blocks I can then
progress the JavaScript and even Python
so it's quite a full-featured
environment for all intensive purposes
it looks like like a very high-level
language but it actually runs at the
speed of C and C++ so that's kind of the
interesting thing and so that enables us
to run on these tiny microcontrollers
that teddy was talking about earlier
another challenge was the connecting of
these devices and the networking of
these devices together
Teddy mentioned we've we've we've been
using the audio jack so we've we've
developed a new serial protocol called
Jack duck and it runs over the audio
jack and the audio jack provides power
data and ground and jack deck is
designed to be very dynamic and plug and
play and the reason for this is that for
fashion designers they're not
electronics engineers they have no real
ability so we want to make it super easy
for these designers to come in plug
different microcontrollers together and
build their applications using an easy
programming environment and an intuitive
protocol so I've got a little demo here
I'm not sure you got it ok so when I
shake my my motion beat which is an
accelerometer
you'll see the lights at the factor nan
and that's all using the the protocol
and the protocol as I mentioned is
designed to be dynamic and they find the
move the tab oh sorry my bad and and
some of these devices also operate USB
so we can collect one of these devices
so this one's running both Jack back
here it's connected to the jack deck bus
and it's also
connected over to over USB and using the
power of web USB I can connect to that
device and I can visualize the activity
that's happening on the bus so I get a
list of my devices and a list of packets
out there are currently being sent on
the bus and I can shake it and you can
see the lights turning on and you see
the packets appearing and that's project
Oliver